a whole new kind of mask showdown caught
on camera this is in southern california
a couple refusing to wear
masks and then threatening to sue the
store owner
for denying them service good afternoon
thanks for joining us here at 4 30. i'm
denise feldick
and i'm kirsten joyce that store owner
is shocked in speaking out
stacy butler has the story you can
record all you want
because look at california civil code 51
look it up
if you're going to discriminate against
me because i have a medical condition
you can personally be sued and it'd
probably be the big that
be the end of this business when this
couple walked into frappe's frozen
yogurt on saturday threatening to sue
for discrimination
because the co-owner required they wear
a mask marianna tabula didn't know what
to say what's your name
your name is your name is marianna if
you're refusing service
no you're you're discriminating and
you're breaking the law and you can be
personally sued you
realize that thank you very much
responsibility
they don't give me any opportunity to
offer
extra face masks just strongly jump on
me to say you broke the law
when the couple threatened to sue her
personally for violating the
constitution
to protect herself she started recording
you know what
when when all this goes away whatever it
does we'll never come back again
so what is your name california civil
code 51. that's your name
i'd have to tell you that tabla says
other nearby business owners told her
the couple threatened to sue them as
well for requiring masks
tabla shared the video with a friend who
posted it on facebook
from there it went viral tabla has
struggled to stay open during the
pandemic
she was disheartened when the couple
returned wednesday
demanding she signed these papers that
state it's illegal to require customers
to wear masks
we lost almost 80 percent to the
customers because the people is afraid
to show
the people is scary and we are too
i'm just trying to keep my business
open and safe
tonight customers are pouring in from
all over the southland
just to support her they were being so
unkind and there's a pandemic
we drove from long beach because it just
was so
disheartening they were so rude and so
mean
i just felt like it was our duty as you
know
fellow mission viejo people to come in
here and support this business
it's like when you used to see the no
shirts no shoes no service type of thing
it's the same thing with the mask now
you can't treat people the way
she was treated so i would like to
support her and i think everybody should
come down here
that was a great show of support local
businesses have been dealing with
incidents like this as well we'll show
you how
they are responding in a live report
coming up tonight at 6